you know I will never get used to seeing
the liberal media defending the Pope
it's a very unused to it now with Pope
Francis but there has been a with Pope
Francis there has been over the years
just a drastic change in strategy for
the liberal media as it pertains to the
Pope up until Pope Francis for as long
as the liberal media's existed their
strategy has been to paint the Pope as a
slobbering dangerous bigot who came here
in a time machine from the 11th century
and is is his dead set on enslaving
mankind you know that's that's basically
how the Pope has always been painted
then Pope Francis comes along and
everything changes
so now that Francis has been credibly
accused of helping to cover up for a
serial sex predator if this same thing
had happened its exact same story with
someone high-ranking official coming out
with this kind of report about say Pope
Benedict or even jp2 before him if that
had happened the media would be they
they'd be having a parade they'd be
throwing a parade through the street and
they would also be this would be
headline news everywhere they'd be
obsessed with it'll be the only thing
they're talking about now
the media has I'm not saying that
they've ignored the story about Francis
obviously we've all heard about it
they've been talking about it and they
have made a moderately big deal about it
but they have not made as big a deal out
of it as it actually is because this is
something in the 2000 years the church
has existed this to my knowledge is
unprecedented or at least it is
extremely extremely extremely rare
that you have allegations like this
coming from someone as high ranking as
Vigano and they're not anonymous she's
putting his name to it and he's accusing
the Pope of these dastardly deeds and
calling from the for him to step down I
mean it's just it never happens and not
only that but the Catholic Church sex
scandal has obviously been an ongoing
story for years now in the media and now
you have evidence that it goes all the
way to the top to the Pope himself I'm
telling you if this had happened seven
years ago it would be the only thing the
media talked about for weeks as opposed
to time treating it as you know an
important story but not necessarily the
most important sort but more than that
it's there has been in the liberal media
the explicit attempts to defend Francis
and circle the wagons or out of I read
for instance in Slate okay that is a
rabid left-wing publication they
published an article giving us reasons
to doubt the claims against Pope Francis
and then there was there was a similar
thing that I've seen similar things in
places like CBS News and then in The New
York Times which has no love for the
Catholic Church at all they published an
article the headline of it is Vatican
power struggle bursts into open as
conservatives pounced so you know that
has been the the the meme is that
whenever a liberal which Pope Francis
liberal never liberal gets himself into
trouble the the story in the media isn't
the terrible thing this liberal did or
is accused of doing it's look at those
awful opportunistic conservatives
pouncing on the news so Pope Francis
credibly accused of covering up for a
serial sex predator and the New York
Times their headline is conservatives
pounced now let's just briefly review in
case I'm sure you've heard the story by
now but but in case you're not familiar
or you haven't been able to make heads
or tails of it yet let's just review
this very quickly Jimmy as I said a
former high-ranking official in the
Catholic Church
Archbishop Carlo Maria Vigano is
essentially the Vatican's ambassador to
the United States he claims that Pope
Francis personally helped cover up
abuses of the degenerate predator
Cardinal McCarrick Vigano
let all this come out in an 11 page
report which he says he was publishing
to discharge his conscience so that he
can present himself to God in order to
to you know present himself to God with
a clean conscience as the is the phrase
I think he used 77 years old he's
preparing to die
and so he's letting all this out and
then from there he proceeds to nuke the
whole network of perverts from orbit
basically Vigano spends the first half
of his report accusing numerous
Cardinals and bishops by name then he
gets to Francis himself he claims that
Francis knew about Cardinal McCarrick
took no actions against me actually
lifted sanctions that Pope Benedict had
placed on him and since then there's bit
there's been a lot of talk now about
this about this this facet of the
accusation this idea that Pope Benedict
placed sanctions on McCarrick and then
Francis lifted the sanctions now that's
something the the fact that there were
sanctions on McCarrick is something that
Vigano says he got secondhand from
someone else that person has come
forward and said yes it's true he's
corroborated since then Pope Benedict's
people have reportedly confirmed that
there were sanctions and church Milty
the website church militant they did a
report yesterday where they pointed out
they pointed to at least two articles in
the news media prior to all this there's
one from a few weeks ago and then
another from four years ago which makes
reference to sanctions or punishments or
penalties that were placed on Cardinal
McCarrick so it seems very much that
there were these sanctions on mckarrick
which Francis then lifted even though
Francis knew about Cardinal McCarrick
and he knew about Cardinal McCarrick
for
because everybody did but second because
Vigano talked to him personally and told
him personally about what McCarrick had
been up to yet francis kept him in a
position on only kept in a position of
power and visibility but also but but in
fact reinstated him reinstalled him into
that position so that he could continue
in his predation in a couple of days
since these stunning allegations were
made there as I said there's been
there's been a corroborating testimony
from one of the people that was
mentioned in Booga nose letter he came
out and said it's true there we have the
we have the the reported confirmation
from Benedict's people then Cardinal
Burke and a bishop in Texas have
categories he categorized the
allegations as credible and called for a
thorough investigation
then another Bishop Bishop Snyder came
out with the strongest reaction yet I
think saying that there is quote no
reasonable and plausible cause to doubt
the truth of the document of Archbishop
Carlo Maria Vigano no reasonable cause
to doubt its truth
now he's not saying that he knows for a
fact it's true but that is a strong
strong statement in fact let me read a
little bit he issued a hold this
Archbishop Schneider issued a whole
statement I won't read the entire thing
but he says it is a rare and an
extremely grave fact in church history
that a bishop accuses publicly and
specifically a reigning Pope quite
Catholics all over the world the simple
faithful the little ones are deeply
shocked and scandalized about recently
described disclosed grave cases in which
church authorities covered up and
protected clerics who committed sexual
offences against minors and against
their own subordinates such a historical
situation which in searches experienced
in our days requires absolute
transparency on all levels of the
church's hierarchy and in first place
evidently on behalf of the Pope and and
then he goes on to say there's no reason
to doubt to doubt the truth content of
the claims so it's strong stuff Pope
Francis as we talked about yesterday
chose not to respond to the allegations
at all which is I mean it's deranged he
said he's not going to say a word about
this and he actually encouraged the
public to draw its own conclusions and
said quote make your own judgment
now I cannot conceive of that it seems
inexplicable doesn't if you were now put
yourself in in Pope Francis's shoes from
it let's let's let's say sake of
argument that Pope Francis is innocent
let's say that you were Pope Francis and
you're innocent and you're accused
somebody makes up a story about you
covering up sexual abuse makes up this
whole detailed elaborate story and then
you're asked about it by the media
you've got cameras you've got a
microphone and you're someone says did
this happen is there any scenario you
can imagine where you would decline to
at least deny it where you would say
well draw your own conclusions about it
oh well he claims that I was that I
covered up sexual abuse but you could
draw your own conclusion Aereo where an
innocent person would decline to issue a
denial of a thing that he did not do so
there are a lot of reasons to believe
that the allegations are true but are
they true
I think in fact I could point to at
least seven reasons why I think the
allegations are credible seven reasons
number one the ganas report is detailed
and well documented
so it has the marks of something that is
true to Vigano is a high-ranking
official with lots of knowledge of the
inner workings of the church this is
this is not some random person this is a
this is a high-ranking or was a
high-ranking important person he knows
what he's talking about three Vigano has
everything to lose by lying nothing that
I can tell to gain for several
trustworthy people have vouched for
díganos credibility five other
trustworthy people have vouched for the
for the actual for the for the truth of
the claims themselves six we have the
background now you know we have certain
background knowledge of the players
involved so we know that some of the
people that were accused like McCarrick
obviously and guys like Worrell we know
that their dere dishonest and cowards
and so we know that and then seven we
have the total lack of a denial from
Pope Francis so I think that those are
seven reasonable justifications for
believing that these accusations are
credible now as i wrote a piece
yesterday and i was you know trying to
make the case but what what can be done
from this point to actually confirm
Vigano x' claims or fully refute them
and i think I think for that there are
four things that need to happen number
one all of the documents letters memos
etc that Vigano mentions in his report
and he says that there are many out
there that will confirm and corroborate
what he's saying all of those but have
to be released to the public number two
every person in the Vatican hierarchy
with any knowledge of the situation has
to come forward and speak number three a
full investigation has to be conducted
and number four Pope Francis has to
answer these charges personally and not
through statements issued by Vatican
lawyers because if you work if he
declines to comment that he goes back to
the comforts of the Vatican few days
later he issues some lawyerly statement
that is just going to make people even
more suspicious
now if none of these measures are taken
then I think that the Catholic faithful
and people all across the world will
have no choice but to assume that a
cover-up is ongoing
Francis is involved in it he will have
left them no other option Pope Francis
can no longer be given the benefit of
the doubt he can no longer just let this
Fester let the doubt Fester because if
he lets it fester then then I think the
benefit of the doubt has to go to vegan
oh it is up to him now to offer some
evidence to prove that these claims are
untrue and if he's not going to do that
then we have no choice but to assume
that they are true and if the
allegations are true as I said yesterday
Pope Francis has to resign because he
would lack the moral capacity to lead
and if he will not lead if he will not
resign I should say then he has to be
pushed out
as for pushing the Pope out
sorry I said that yesterday a lot of
people have have you know this is I'm
not the only one who's been saying this
and there are others who have objected
saying well there's it's really no way
to push a pope out I mean what are you
talking about there's no reason to talk
about it because it's impossible to do I
don't think that's true
I think there is a way to get rid of a
pope if you want to put it that way
that's how you want to phrase it to my
knowledge there isn't any mechanism in
place to officially have the Pope
removed from office so in that in that
sense there is nothing we can do but in
that same sense we as individuals have
little power to have anyone in any
context removed from any position you
couldn't even get the you couldn't even
get rid of the local dominos assistant
manager in your neighborhood if you
wanted to I mean you you you couldn't do
it on your own
you you personally really cannot remove
anyone from anything if we're being
honest right you and I are people of
with basically no power and on our own
we can't remove anyone from anything but
as groups we have virtually I think
unlimited power in these kinds of
situations because if the group is large
enough and loud enough and consistent
enough it can basically push anyone from
any position if the position is dominos
assistant manager well then the group
probably doesn't need to be that large
if the position is is you know some
political office then the the group
needs to be much much larger but it can
happen for the Pope the group needs to
be extremely extremely extremely large
but it can happen and this needs to be a
group that is armed with prayer and
righteous anger
if it turns out that the Pope is guilty
and it's not looking good for him
let's be honest but if these allegations
can be confirmed or if there is enough
corroboration so as to make the fact
completely overwhelmingly clear or if
the Pope as I said tries to ignore this
completely and thus proves the existence
of a cover-up by his lack of denial in
his lack of action well then I think
it'll be time for Catholics to rise up
around the globe to take to the streets
organize rallies but pressure on their
bishops to to put pressure themselves on
the Vatican
that's that's what I mean by pressuring
pushing it's just a matter if we get to
this point I'm not saying we're there
yet but if we get to this point then
it's a matter of rising up making your
anger known and saying this is
unacceptable this is intolerable this
man does not have the moral capacity to
lead and so he must do the right thing
and step aside ultimately he has to make
that choice on his own but I think
um I don't even think the most arrogant
Pope in the world in the history could
remain in office in face of a worldwide
backlash from his own ranks maybe I'm
wrong but I don't think so so if we
reach that point it is not true to say
that regular Catholic lay people are
powerless they do have quite a lot of
power actually even more power than that
when you consider that the Catholic
Church largely relies on them for
funding so that's power that we have as
well
and I think we can use it now this there
are many things about this that are
unprecedented and the idea of lay people
rising up and demanding this kind of
change that is I mean that is certainly
on precedent that has never happened
part of the reason why though that's
never happened is because just the
situation is different in modern times
back in the old days if there was
controversy in the church if there was
scandal whatever the average guy sitting
in a pew probably never would have heard
of it
the average peasant farmer in 1735
wouldn't have heard most of these
controversies are scandals or if he did
hear about them he would have heard
about them after the fact after some
proclamation or whatever is issued and
then he would go oh okay well I guess
that's settled
but now we have with just the nature of
the modern world living in the
Information Age that we do we have
insight we have we have a window into
all of these machinations as they're
ongoing
as regular people we have a choice to
make because do we just sit back and
hope that the people in power do the
right thing
well it's clear we cannot hope for that
because that has not been happening and
the other choice is to stand up and let
our voices be heard
we're calling not in that case we'd be
calling not for vengeance not for
anything like that but standing for what
is true it was what is right
and demanding that morality and basic
order be restored
which i think is a very good
holy thing
so if we reach that point I think there
are that is the that is a tool
that we have at our disposal and we
should not rule out using that tool if
we get there
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody Godspeed